في اليوم العالمي للمياه حذرت الامم
المتحده من ان الاستهلاك المفرطه للمياه
والتغير المناخي جعل نقص المياه مستوطنا
في جميع انحاء العالم ما ادى الى خطر وشيك
بحدوث ازمه عالميه وتشكل النزاعات نزاعات
المياه تحديدا جانبا من المشهد العالمي
الراهن بسبب نوبات الجفاف والزياده
الاستهلاك وتنتشر تلك النزاعات في عده
مناطق من العالم لكن ابرزها الصراع القائم
بين دول حوض النيل لا سيما بين دولتي
المصاب مصر والسودان من جهه واثيوبيا من
جهه اخرى بعد انشائها سد النهضه اكبر
السدود في قاره افريقيا وتعتبره القاهره
والخرطوم منافيا للاتفاقيات ويضر بحصتيما
المائيتين كما تشكل المياه احد جوانب
الصراع بين العرب واسرائيل فالاردن مثلا
لا يحصل على كامل حصته المائيه من نهر
الاردن لان اسرائيل تحتكر ت ومياه الابار
الجوفيه بمنطقه وادي عربه والغمر اما
بحيره طبريه فكانت من ابرز اسباب فشل
سوريا واسرائيل في ابرام لتسويه بينهما
حيث تخضع البحيره ذات المياه العذبه
للسيطره الاسرائيليه الكامله ولاهميتها
البالغه ترفض تل ابيب التخلي عنها سلما او
حربا وكثيرا ما فجرت مياه نهر دجله
والفرات ازمات بين تركيا وكل من العراق
وسوريا وتقول بغداد انها اصبحت تعاني في
السنوات الاخيره نقصا مائيا حادا بسبب
السدود التركيه المقامه على منابع النهرين
وخصوصا سد ايليسو الذي بني عند منبع نهر
دجله ما في شبه القاره الهنديه يعتبر نهر
الاندوس المعروف بنهر السند عامل نزاع
قويا بين باكستان والهند فحصه باكستان
المائيه من النهر تمر اليها عبر الجزء
الخاضع من اقليم كشمير وقد لجات الهند عام
2019 الى وقف تدفق روافه السند الى
باكستان التي تعتبر من اكثر دول العالم
نقصا في المياه وفضلا عما يؤجزه من نزاعات
تكشف ازمه المياه في العالم عن تداعيات
خطيره على حياه الافراد والمجتمعات
يوم امس قال تقرير لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
ان ملياري شخص على الاقل في العالم يشربون
مياها ملوثه وغير صالحه ما يسبب انتقال
امراضا مثل الاسهال والكوليرا والتيفوئيد
وشلل الاطفال
ويقدر ويقدر تقرير منظمه الصحه عدد
الوفيات الناجمه عن الاسهال كل عام بنحو
نصف مليون لاسمه في البلدان الاقل نموا
وكانت تقريرا الاقتصادي العربي الموحد
لعام الف لعام 2020 قد وقع انخفاض نصيب
الفرد من العذبه في المنطقه العربيه الى
667 متر مكعبا بحلول عام
وذلك سيكون خمس مكان عليه الحال قبل سبعين
عاما وكشف ايضا التقرير ان مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه لقطاع المياه في المنطقه العربيه
تحتاج الى 200 مليار دولار في الفتره بين
و25 على كلا ينضم الينا من مدينه اوبسالا
في السويد الدكتور الشوبس وين استاذ ابحاث
السلام والنزاعات في جامعه اوبسالا
والخبير في مجال النزاعات الدوليه حول
المياه سيد مرحبا بك معنا ما خطوره ما
يجري الان من شح في المياه للاسباب
العديده التي ذكرنا جزءا منها في مناطق
نزاع هي في الاساس متوتره
نعم ان صحه الموارد المائيه اصبحت خطيره
والباحثون الذي المعنيون بهذه الامور
وصناع السياسات
ورجال السياسه يتحدثون عن خطوره صحه ونظره
المياه على الاقل لاربعه عقود الله لكنها
في في بسبب تداعيات الثغرات المناخيه زادت
تفاقما الان نرى البلدان تتحارب وتتقاتل
على مصادر
المياه هناك تغيرات مع ذلك
احدثتها الطائرات المناخيه لانها هذه
التغيرات
زادت من شحه المياه وزادت من الطلب عليه
ثانيا نرى ايضا هناك تغيرا على الصعيد
السياسي هناك تحالفات سياسيه جديده تتشكل
وهذا بدوره يغير سلوكيات
البلدان تجاه اداره الموارد المائيه ما
سنراه هو اندلاع نزاعات جديده اضافه الى
تفاقم النزاعات قائمه حاليا في السنوات
المقبله ونرى ايضا في بعض المناطق نظرت
وشحه المياه
ستؤدي الى حروب اهليه داخل البلد نفسه
عندما نرى ان الامر مرتبط بشحه المياه
من وجهه نظرك ومتابعتك الحديثه لهذا الملف
ملف النزاع
المتعلق اكثر بالمياه وشحها اي المناطق
الاكثر يعني المهدده اكثر من غيرها بمثل
هذه النزاعات وتفاجرها لهذه الاسباب
صحه نظره المياه في الحقيقه
وخاصه في شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
وجنوب اسيا هذه هي المناطق التي نرى فيها
ان شحه المواد المياه المائيه
يمكن ان تؤدي الى نشوب نزعته هناك في
مناطق اخرى نزاعات كانت موجوده لكن زياده
عدد السكان وايضا هم من الناحيه المناخيه
اكثر هشاشه كذلك تاثر
الانهار الرئيسيه التي مثل
النهرين الفرات والنهر النيل وايضا هناك
عدد من هذه الانهار الدوليه لا توجد حولها
اتفاقات لتوزيعها الحصص المائيه هذا ما
يزيد من احتمالي نشوب
النزاع طبعا
في الهند وفاكستان ايضا هناك مشكله حول
نهر السن اضافه الى التوترات الموجوده
اصلا لهذا السبب سنرى تكرر الازمات هي
تحدث منها الان لكن سنراها تزداد تساقبا
في المستقبل شكرا لك من مدينه اوبسالا في
السويد الدكتور اوشوكس وين استاذ ابحاث
السلام والنزاعات في جامعه اوكسلا والخبير
في مجال نزاعات الدوليه حول المياه شكرا
على المشاركه